AYO DOSUNMU  DID A GOOD JOB
GRABBING DeMAR DeROZAN.
>> Robbie: HE WANTS A REVIEW .
YOU GET TO TORREY CRAIG CUTTING
TO THE BASKET.
HE WAS EMPHATIC ABOUT IT.
CREDIT AYO DOSUNMU . YOU ARE
RIGHT, ADAM.
>> Adam: THERE WAS A CHALLENGE
OPPORTUNITY . ONE-POINT GAME.
FINAL SECONDS.
BULLS  LOOK FOR THE WIN.
DeROZAN. DeMAR DeROZAN DELIVERS!
>> Adam: A HERCULES SHOT FROM
DeMAR DeROZAN!
>> Adam: WHAT A SHOT BY DeMAR
DeROZAN.
THEY WILL LOOK TO SEE IF IT
STANDS, AND IT IS CONFIRMED.
DeMAR DeROZAN COMES RIGHT TO
THE HEADSET. THIS WAS A TOUGH
ONE TONIGHT.
THE PACERS PUSHED YOU.
IT WAS A TOUGH NIGHT FOR YOU.
WALK ME THROUGH THE FINAL PLAY
THAT WINS IT.
>> I TRIED TO GET A STOP.
WE GOT A MUCH NEEDED STOP. WE
GOT THE BALL. WE COULD EITHER
WIN OR GO HOME.
I JUST WANTED TO GET A GOOD
LOOK AT THE RIM.
>> GIVE ME A SENSE OF YOU IN
THOSE MOMENTS.
EVERYONE HAS SPOKEN ABOUT YOUR
POINT IN THE FOURTH QUARTER,
BUT IN THE FINAL SECONDS OF THE
GAME, IS YOUR HEAD CLEAR?
>> YOU HAVE GOT TO KEEP A LEVEL
HEAD.
YOU KNOW, ENJOY THE MOMENTS. IT
WAS ONE OF THOSE TYPES OF
GAMES.
WE STUCK WITH IT. I'VE GOT TO
GIVE CREDIT TO MY TEAMMATES. WE
KEPT FIGHTING AND KEPT FIGHTING.
>> Adam: DeMAR DeROZAN WITH A
PHENOMENAL SHOT IN THE FOURTH
QUARTER TO WIN IT .
CONGRATULATIONS.
AN ABSOLUTELY CLUTCH,
INCREDIBLE SHOT TO PUT THE
BULLS 13 GAMES OVER 500 FOR THE
FIRST TIME SINCE 2015.
>> Robbie: IT MIGHT NOT GO
DOWN IN THE BOX SCORE AS HIS
GREATEST GAME, BUT ON THE
STRETCH DeMAR DeROZAN MADE
EVERY PLAY.
NOW THERE IS 0.7 ON THE SHOT
CLOCK.
HE MAKES THE PLAY AT THE RIM AT
THE END OF THE GAME. I MEAN,
THIS IS JUST ABSURD.
FADING AWAY, DeMAR DeROZAN, MR.
FOURTH QUARTER.
WHAT A PERFORMANCE AND WHAT A
WIN FOR THE BULLS.
>> Adam: